et
pour éviter les accidents les shadoks
ont décidé de ranger la terre mais les
déménageurs shadoks n'y comprennent rien
ils ne sont pas assez éduqués et du qui
les shadoks oui malheureusement c'était
pas une chose facile
les cerveaux des shadows qu'on ait fait
avec une capacité est tout à fait limité
il ne comportait dans tout que quatre
cas et encore c'était pas toujours vrai
parce que bien souvent il y en avait
deux bouchées pour remplir les cases
déjà c'était pas facile et cela prenait
un certain temps c'est alors que
commence aime la difficulté parce que
collet case était plein il y avait plus
de place et le chat d'oc
on ne pouvait plus rien lui apprendre si
on essayait quand même alors
obligatoirement il y avait une case qui
se vidait pour faire de la place
un sorte que quand shadoks avec une tête
plein voulez apprendre quelque chose il
fallait qu'ils en oublient une autre
exemple si un shadok avait appris à
marcher avec une case et que plus tard
il est a pris trois mots avec les trois
autres cases et bien si en plus on
voulait lui apprendre à faire du vélo le
chat d'oc ne savait plus marcher comme
il n'avait que quatre cases
évidemment les shadoks ne connaissais
pas plus que quatre mots s'était garé
but zoo et me
ouais ouais vous comprendrez donc
facilement qu'il n'y avait pas du tout
suffisamment de mots pour toutes les
choses qui existaient et il y avait des
quantités de choses qui avait le même
mot dans ces conditions que le cran
l'eau d'aménagement sadok de la terre
risquait de poser certaines difficultés
[Musique]